[موسيقى]
يعني انا اعتقد ان محمد صلاح يمثل قوه
العرب والمسلمين النائمه يعني وتحديدا قوه
العرب الذين يعني ينظرون يعني تعرف في
المجتمعات الغربيه هناك صوره نمطيه عن
العربي لكن حينما يتقدم مشروع مثل مشروع
محمد صلاح بهذا التواضع بهذه المهاره بهذه
الاحترافيه بهذا العزم بهذه الروح التي
يعني لا تندهن بسهوله في صورته وهو يعني
يتفاعل مع جماهير ليفربول
تجد ان يعني محمد صلاح عليه اجماع كبير
[موسيقى]
لا تخلو مباراه من النشيد باسمه مو صلاح
وبالتالي رفع يعني صوره واحيانا من محبتهم
له يرفعون شعارات كاريكاتيريه له بدافع
الحب وهو يعني اصبح جزءا من هذا النسيج ان
شاء الله على امل على امل يا دكتور ان يتم
يعني صناعه نجوم ايضا عرب اخرين من الاردن
من السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]